est-ce que ça court très vite parce que
sa vie dans les grandes plaines
africaines où j'ai pas fait attention
sur la route
jerry
on sait qu'ils vont tenir prêtes
oui
on a perdu la cote s moscou étendoir la
vie
nous la connaissons aura disparu dans 90
jours c'est à tout changer ça je ne
laisserai pas ma famille ne faites pas
comme si votre famille n'était pas
parlons de la fin de l'humanité
été envoyées depuis cette installation
personnes s'est donné la peine de lire
us commencent en russie c'est le black
out j'ai besoin de réponses
ces choses sont un peu faibles chaque
humain tenues souvent
et en deux mois accompagnent